[Música]
buenos días
cuando hablamos de dejar un legado más
sostenible a nuestras futuras
generaciones a mí al menos me ocurre que
siempre me viene a la mente ideas como
el medio ambiente y la sostenibilidad
bueno y eso está muy bien ciertamente es
lógico conceptos como la reutilización y
el reciclaje adquieren aún un mayor
significado haciéndonos ser conscientes
de alguna manera de la importancia que
tiene aplicar e implementar pequeñas
acciones en nuestro presente para así
poder modificar nuestro futuro mirad por
ejemplo reciclando dos piezas de vidrio
como éstas se obtiene la batería
suficiente para manejar un smartphone de
última generación durante un montón de
horas un smartphone como este que veis
aquí pero mirad como la magia también es
una sucesión de pequeñas acciones pilas
vais a flipar
el móvil ha desaparecido
esto lo veis todos los días con un
aplaudir
en fin soy miguel de luca soy mago
ilusionista profesional y mi mundo es
ese el de la ilusión un mundo donde todo
absolutamente todo es posible un mundo
donde además de cumplir nuestros propios
sueños podemos ayudar a los demás a
cumplir los suyos no me digáis que no
sería maravilloso poder dejar un mundo
así a nuestros hijos un mundo sostenible
sí pero emocionalmente hablando un mundo
que tuviera mucho más que ver con la
ilusión que con la desesperanza un mundo
que tuviera mucho más que ver con él si
quiere con él si puedo con él no tengo
ganas o no me apetece un mundo donde la
autoestima no se me dirá en likes y un
mundo donde para decirnos las verdaderas
cosas importantes nos pudiéramos mirar a
los ojos y no a través de una pantalla
creo que este mundo es posible' y aquí
os lanzó la primera idea
este mundo es posible gracias a la magia
porque para mí y para muchas personas la
magia es la capacidad de ver posibles
aquellas cosas que en un principio
parecen imposibles recordad la magia es
la capacidad de ver posibles aquellas
cosas que parecen imposibles
bienvenidos a legados mágicos
sostenibles
[Música]
[Aplausos]
dicen que los magos nunca podemos
revelar nuestros secretos yo hoy aquí
voy a hacer una pequeña excepción y es
que un viejo amigo del que mucho aprendí
me contó que el secreto para dejar un
mundo mejor era el que posiblemente no
tengáis ni idea de lo que es el ea y a
mí me pasaba igual cada vez que
escuchaba esta expresión
y no sé por qué pero dentro de mí tenía
la necesidad de buscar en alguna
dirección miraba arriba abajo a la
derecha de izquierda miraba delante de
mí incluso detrás mirada por todos los
lados y nunca encontré nada eso si llega
un momento que conseguí conectar todo y
lo hice cuando deje de mirar fuera y
miré dentro de mí encontré el verdadero
significado
y emoción
amor ilusión la emoción el amor y la
ilusión que curiosamente son los tres
valores que desde siempre han dado
sentido a mi vida profesional y son los
tres valores que siempre que me subo a
un escenario o grande o pequeño me da
igual intento poner en alza la emoción
el amor y la ilusión pero hay algo que
me preocupa y que me gustaría compartir
con vosotros quizá entre todos demos con
la solución pero no sé por qué pero a
medida que nos vamos haciendo mayores
la perspectiva y la potencia y la
cercanía que sentimos hacia la emoción
el amor y la ilusión cambia
sustancialmente incluso en algunas
personas llega a desaparecer y aquí va
mi segunda idea
perder la emoción el amor y la ilusión
es algo completamente insostenible
no nos lo podemos permitir bajo ningún
concepto es como si de alguna manera nos
enseñan a percibir la vida desde una
misma óptica cuántas veces he escuchado
que para disfrutar de la magia solo se
aplica el sentido de la vista
para acceder a este mundo sostenible del
que yo estoy hablando hay que aplicar 5
6 7 incluso 8 sentidos y me gustaría
hacer una experiencia mira voy a
necesitar la ayuda de una persona que no
esté por aquí muy cerca no sé si por
ejemplo mira ahí ve un señor de blanco
que es muy grande
y la chica que está a tu lado me pueden
ver por favor simplemente
un fuerte aplauso
qué tal estás bienvenida nos conocemos
como es tu nombre estefanía muy bien
mira lo que vamos a hacer una cosa
estefanía te llaman asiste familia
siempre funny wolfan y mira hagamos una
cosa de que dirías que son estos vasos
de cristal muy bien porque como os digo
para percibir la magia no sólo hace
falta la vista sino también el sentido
del oído mira
voy a colocar un vaso pequeño aquí
y te entrego una moneda
fanny si yo te pido que lances una
moneda a uno de los dos vasos que vaso
ligeras no lo vas a hacer tranquila este
grande pero nunca sería magia sería
suerte habilidad su puntería de verdad
muy bien hoy es un día muy especial yo
creo para todos para mí el primero y hay
que hacer un poquito de magia mirad voy
a el vaso grande y voy a tapar el
vaso pequeño
para que sea completamente imposible que
la moneda entra y como estamos hablando
además
de los sentidos para agudizar nuestro
sentido del oído os voy a privar del
sentido de la vista
fanning déjame la moneda por favor y
extiende tu mano derecha así
y cierra los ojos de todo el mundo de
acuerdo aquí no hay trampa porque esto
es magia de verdad
una moneda dos monedas y tres monedas y
perfecto
la mano así que no abra la mano por el
mundo
es que es muy cariñoso la primera moneda
bueno no habrás escuchado una
un momento
cuántas monedas tienes dos
estás alucinando yo no porque sé cómo se
hace si no estaría en un momento que se
vea por favor como realmente está la
moneda y ellos cuando la gente realmente
aplausos
está bonito no te vayas te vayas
fanny vamos a hacerlo con una segunda
moneda aquí
aquí quieres verlo compañero sin pañuelo
sí sí
así que voy a una cosa muy sencilla casi
dos monedas verdad
se vean bien voy a cerrar la mano
es importante que la sangre circule para
que llegue al final de la conferencia si
no muero antes cierro a mano
2 y 3
pero mira funny con esta última moneda
vamos a hacer algo más difícil todavía
fanny efe
y mi nombre miguel
efe
es cierto que ha salido un poco un poco
así porque sabes por qué porque me llamó
la atención el caballero que estaba
sentado a tu lado porque es un tipo así
grande va vestido de blanco y se le ve
muy bien pero digo sales genérico lo
alto que es me deja mi pequeño pues no
entonces traer algo pequeñito irá ahora
de verdad
déjame la moneda firmada por ti por mí
quiero que me coge la mano y por debajo
también funny sin pañuelo vale vamos me
encanta porque a la gente no sabes si
mirar a la mano con mirar al base
algunos en primera fila se queda bizco
ya verás giro en mi mano entre tu mano
pero por favor no quiero que os quedéis
solo con lo bien que lo estamos pasando
quiero que penséis todo lo que está
sucediendo en este momento y que luego
vamos a hablar giro mi mano se vea bien
hay una moneda y una
es la fm
un aplauso para funny
bueno como os como os decía me gustaría
que habláramos un poquito de lo que ha
ocurrido no me gusta solo con la magia
yo sé que es alucinante no como tres
monedas incluso la última firmada puede
llegar a entrar en un vaso pequeñito
tapado por un vaso grande pero en
realidad lo que ha ocurrido es que todos
por un momento os habéis concedido la
maravillosa oportunidad de ver como algo
que parece imposible se ha tornado
posible y ese es el secreto os lo digo
de corazón no hay más darnos la
oportunidad visualizar como algo que
parece imposible se ha convertido en
posible la fórmula de la magia es algo
relativamente sencillo y comparto con
vosotros la magia es igual a la actitud
más la aptitud actitud con ci actitud
con la actitud con pe
es la emoción el amor y la ilusión
valores sentimientos ideas que a mí me
han valido la actitud son las ganas de
poner en marcha estos tres valores pero
no os preocupéis no hace falta trabajar
en televisión ni pisar un círculo rojo
para hacer esta magia que ellos
propongan que va todos lo podemos hacer
publicadas mañana cuando sonó el
despertador visar el escenario de
vuestra propia vida de vuestro propio
espectáculo de magia esta vida nos va a
poner delante a viejos y nuevos actores
con los que poder empezar a interactuar
de una manera diferente os pongo un
ejemplo básico pero también me sirve
mucho una vecina con la que llevamos
conviviendo muchos años ya la que nunca
hemos saludado y por fin le dedicamos
una pequeña sorpresa no subestimes el
valor de las pequeñas cosas si
estuviéramos hablando de temas
empresariales tan de moda ahora
podríamos decir que tenemos un producto
un producto que todo el mundo quiere
comprar que es la emoción en la memoria
y la visión y que todo el mundo que no
sea mago sabe poner en el mercado ahora
bien sólo queda hacerlo y es la cuarta
idea que orlando que no sólo se cree en
el plano de las ideas
en el plano cognitivo sino también en el
plano conductual
mira cuando yo actúe en cualquier sitio
ya sea el programa de la tele o sea el
escenario más pequeñito o el más grande
intento hacer varias cosas la primera y
más importante es que para que suceda la
magia entre mi espacio que hoy está
representado por este círculo rojo tan
significativo vuestro espacio que está
representado por ese patio de butacas y
el caminito que hay entre un espacio y
otro yo intento a través de la emoción
del amor y de la ilusión generar un
mundo un pequeño ecosistema
emocionalmente más sostenible sabéis por
qué porque es la única manera de que
realmente suceda la magia
todo esto que os he contado son solo
reflexiones reflexiones de un humilde
ilusionista y espero que estas
reflexiones o se hagan pensar
os hagan saber disfrutar y como no
reflexionar sobre algo que considero que
es muy importante
y estoy convencido de ello solo tenéis
que mirar a vuestro alrededor y veréis
cómo hay gente que día a día hace magia
parece ser que hoy en día en este mundo
de estrés prisas y responsabilidades es
muy complicado para el pse hacer magia
pero todos somos adultos y sabemos a la
magia que yo me refiero
5 ideas
escritas que me gustaría lanzar la
primera idea ver a través de la magia
como lo que parece imposible se puede
convertir en posible la segunda idea
la emoción el amor y la ilusión es algo
completamente sostenible y que nos
ayudará a hacer de este mundo algo mucho
mejor idea que por supuesto lanzó la
tercera idea la fórmula de la magia la
actitud más la aptitud la cuarta idea
que no se quede todo en el plano
cognitivo que lo pongamos en marcha y la
quinta idea que siempre me ha acompañado
y que me hace muy feliz y que me hace
tener una vida realmente plena cuando
consigo trasladar las técnicas que yo
aplicó en el escenario a mi vida
personal y es que todos absolutamente
todos aunque no os lo creáis tenéis un
mago dentro os invito a descubrirlo
[Aplausos]